chris we had this comment come in
overnight and so beautifully written i
wanted to read it it's from user half
xbreed23
and they write i think a lot of writers
have an obsession with their characters
which keeps the story from growing
because they're too in love with them
nothing is greater than the story nobody
is greater than the story story is the
sun characters are flowers
the story allows characters to bloom
i love that i love that awesome yeah i i
think that's right uh characters
are in service to story
and by story we don't mean plot
the story is the totality
of
the characters
doing what they do as they struggle with
all of the challenges they face
and
a beautiful line
that doesn't support the story has got
to be cut
i
i i think one of the great challenges is
after i've said we should you know dig
into our own defining moments when we
base a character on ourselves
and it becomes too autobiographical
that can limit us
because one of the things we have to
look at are the characters flaws and
complexities and i don't want to
think about my complexities my
where am i a hypocrite
put that on the page for the world
so if
um
if i'm not willing to let the character
and the story go where they need to
i can end up
kind of wrapping duct tape around that
character
and preventing them from
pursuing
their own life
and this sounds
absurd unless you're a writer
characters will surprise us characters
say things we did not know they were
going to say
that's such an electric exciting moment
when that happens
i can't quite explain how that happens
yes if we treat our characters like um
you know the
whatever
antique barbie and ken dolls that we
don't want to take out of their boxes uh
because they're too valuable in their
perfection
uh
we will
hamper
the story that that could unfold if we
let them cut loose a little bit
it's a great analogy yeah so being too
precious like you have your collection
up there
and you can show it
um but you can't really do anything with
it right yeah you got to get the dolls
out of the boxes and play with them
and that's the point of all of this
character development is to get to the
place where we can now
get them out and play with them and put
the astronaut doll in the gemini capsule
and blast it off and see what happens
and you know let barbie and ken fight it
out and see what happens that's
that's the play that happens when we get
past all this character development and
we actually start writing pages
uh that's that's where the fun is that's
where the life
uh comes so
character development is not an end in
itself the story
is the end
chris i heard you say in maybe a michael
we see video that a story is a hero's
struggle against an obstacle to reach a
goal
yes so i
first came across that quote from
television writer bill eidelson
reading an article in the writer's guild
magazine
and
i just have found that to be the e
equals m c squared
of the physics of storytelling
it gives us three elements gives us our
hero
gives us
a goal and then the obstacles against
which the heroes struggles
that's not everything that happens in
story
but it allows us to understand at
an elemental level
what is happening in the story
so
in
steven spielberg's lincoln
it's the story of abraham lincoln
struggling against
all of the forces
of
the u.s house of representatives who
don't want to outlaw slavery
to
pass an amendment to the united states
constitution outlawing slavery
now i didn't try
i just gave you the hero gold obstacle
but i gave you a log line for the movie
and the log line was just the hero goal
obstacle dynamic
put into a sentence
it brings the story into focus
it'll it identifies the single action
that aristotle said that a drama needs
to be about
and it puts the focus on the character's
struggle
so if a story is the hero's struggle
against an obstacle to reach a goal then
the story juice
is in the struggle
and
we so we want to spend most of our
page count
dramatizing that struggle
that gives us
force and focus
for a story it helps us know what the
story is
so we can judge what serves the story
and what doesn't what's a distraction
i
i just find it to be
such a clarifying lens
a story is not only that there's also
claudia hunter johnson wrote a great
book called crafting short screenplays
that connect
and she talks about the power of
connection and disconnection between
characters and how much emotion comes
from connection you can think about a
touch a kiss as a connection or
two characters whose eyes meet and they
realize against all odds they're
actually on the same side
or a disconnection of betrayal
and just
to say betrayal
we feel the emotion
that goes with that
and then there are missed connections
um
near misses longed for connections that
never happen
all of that swirls around
heroes
struggling toward goals against
obstacles
so i find that to be
um so so useful when i'm figuring out
the structure of
a whole movie
or the structure of an individual scene
we can think about even the sprawling
three movies or three books of lord of
the rings
it's all about frodo
carrying a ring to mount doom to destroy
it
struggling against all the forces of
mordor
it's a single action across all three
three-hour long movies
and
the filmmakers never lose sight of what
the story is the story is frodo
struggling against the forces of mordor
to destroy the ring
lots of stuff happens in that movie
and we also we actually kind of feel
the energy drain
when we step away from that
central thread when we're with mary and
pippen in the trees
we sort of feel
the temperature turned down
on the urgency
and the focus of that
tom bombadil which for readers of the
book
they know
there's maybe a hundred pages about some
guy named tom bombadil has nothing to do
with frodo trying to get rid of that
ring
and so
rightly that just falls out
of the movies
because it doesn't serve
the imperative of movies which is all
about what happens next
and hero goal obstacle helps us to know
what we mean when we say well what
happens next is what happens next as the
hero's struggling toward the goal
forgive me you talked about this other
movie and that is that blood diamond yes
okay and i have not seen it but if i'm
keeping with what i believe you said was
sort of this premise it seems like
they're all their common goal is this
diamond or these diamond mines and
having access to them
well so
each in this case we've got
two protagonists we've got leonardo
dicaprio whose goal is
make all the money he can from these
diamonds
and then jimin hansu whose goal is
rescue my son
and so here we've got two stories that
intersect
and
so we could call that uh i think robert
mckee calls that a multi-protagonist
story
which is which is to say you've got
multiple protagonists each with their
own goal
and they succeed or fail
individually
you can also have buddy movies or movies
with
several people on a team
all struggling toward the same goal and
they succeed or fail together and mckee
calls those plural protagonist movies
plural protagonist movies are more of
the classic
structure that we see in say hollywood
movies
multi-protagonist movies are more
arthouse things they're much harder to
do
but you know those movies like crash and
traffic and magnolia that's where you
see
uh and babel
multi-protagonist movies
and i think that's what's going on with
uh blood diamond
right and so
the real goal though isn't this this
diamond the real goal is is the
realization that this father loves his
son and he's trying to save him from
yeah
so it's an interesting thing you've got
um
sort of your stated goal
i i'm going to rescue my son i'm going
to get that diamond
some characters have the wrong goal
or
their need for growth is far more
important
than their stated goal
leonardo dicaprio's
goal
he's got the wrong goal he just wants to
be rich he wants diamonds
that's the wrong goal
what he really needs to do is find
something that is worth more than
diamonds and that's people that's love
and he does
so
the audience recognizes that and they
say oh you didn't get your goal
but you grew in the way you needed to so
i can still feel good about that but
if you die along the way it's
bittersweet and so that's cool you know
it's it's not the the neat bow
whereas
jimin hansu the dad who's looking to
rescue his son
it's not really a story about his
inner growth
for him we are invested in him actually
achieving his goal of rescuing his son
which will require his son's
transformation
so that's where we get the
transformation
and the emotion that accompanies that in
that story
and those two end up being intertwined
uh at the end but they uh
they unfold independently for the first
uh
good part of that movie
you said that mostly art house cinema
does sort of like these multi
protagonist films well
if you've got a multi-protagonist film
it is going to be probably less of a
blockbuster
and so
yes you may end up having an art house
film if you do that
um
[Music]
studio films are going to be
the
more classic single story that we're
telling whether with one protagonist or
many working together so um like a
or a plural protagonist story a lot of
uh protagonists working together would
be the oceans 11 12 13 movies you've got
a team of people who are all trying to
pull off the same heist
and they succeed or fail together